a changing job market and what has been
a very strange year for american workers
on the one hand the number of unemployed
people looking for full-time work has
plunged to the same level it was before
the pandemic but at the same time
americans have been quitting in record
numbers for months leaving 11 million
positions empty coveted of course is one
factor but some experts see this
lingering i quit movement as a sign that
america has plenty of jobs but not
enough of what most consider to be good
ones
on a sunny day in battle creek michigan
hey i'm tony dejean lucious nice to meet
you john we met this 30 year old father
of three what you doing in school today
who for the past two years has worked at
the kellogg cereal plant part of a
decades-old tradition of solid middle
class work here in serial city when you
got the job i was ecstatic i told
everybody that day i called my mom i
told my wife was happy but while many
line workers at kellogg still have a
pension premium health care and great
wages other workers like dejean lucius
have a very different deal
no pension pricier health care and less
pay than colleagues who do the exact
same job we literally work side by side
side by side side by side but you're
making 13 or 15 15 15 less yes so
there's two classes of worker at kellogg
yes
and you're in the lower class yes it's
called a two-tier contract and since the
1980s companies in dozens of industries
have used it to cut costs lowering pay
for new hires like dejohn and turning
what once felt like some of america's
best jobs
into something else
how important would that 15 be to your
life
i could buy a house i could finish
putting up for my kids college savings
that's what i thought i was doing when i
got the job in a statement to cbs news
kellogg's notes the union agreed to a
two-tier system in 2015 which the
company says is not unusual in any
industry as a way to control rising
benefit costs critics like rick wartzman
say that's both true
and the problem
america was more of a we culture and in
more recent decades i think we've become
an eye culture wartzman is the author of
the end of loyalty the rise and fall of
good jobs in america
he details why wages for the typical
worker rose right alongside productivity
after world war ii
but writes that more recently the
corporate compact has come completely
undone
how big of a deal was it for
this compact to break down
for it to break down it's a huge deal
tony this last you know 40 50 year
period we have left so many people
trailing so far behind wartzman blames
familiar changes like automating jobs
and moving them overseas but he also
points to a shift in the culture of
business itself tying ceo pay to the
stock price and valuing investors ahead
of everyone else
so there's a real frankly personal
incentive for all too many to try and do
all kinds of things to see the share
price go up and worry a lot less about
those on the front lines well i got a
check stub here folks like dejean lucius
say they've noticed the same thing so
the money that's not in this check the
money that's not going into your
household right here where is it going
going to the ceo and shareholders
hundreds of kellogg's employees
including those grandfathered in to a
better deal how many people here are
so-called legacy employees
so most of you have been on the picket
line since october
part of a national wave of strikes and
outright resignations
what's in it for you
in this fight if you already have the
benefits and and the money i want my
niece and nephews have what i have right
my child i love my job
my neighbors
my neighbors kids
but with many everyday americans fed up
the question is where can they really go
among the 10 jobs that will add the most
positions in america this decade are
home health aides fast food workers and
general laborers with a median salary of
just over thirty thousand dollars a year
that means many americans like dejean
lucius aren't left with a lot of good
options
for good jobs if you don't do this
what are you gonna
do i have no idea
i don't think it will be any good paying
jobs
this is an example of what i think
everybody needs to fight for
so good paying jobs and where are they
that's the question here and i just want
to underscore that a big takeaway is
that while there is job growth in our
country there is a huge gap between the
jobs that pay well and the ones that
don't so we just put that graphic up
that talked about jobs like home health
aides and fast food workers the typical
salary for those jobs and the top 10
jobs that are going to grow the most and
that you don't need a college degree for
the typical salary is 28 000 a year
actually just shy of that that is many
thousands of dollars less than what is
considered to be a living wage
researchers at mit say that's about 34
000 so there's a big gap there and we're
talking about 16 an hour it's not a huge
number so but finding a job without more
schooling that will pay you at least
that is really hard to do in this
country and there are a lot of reasons
but one big one that experts point to
is that there is an incentive for
executives and people at the top to
prioritize investors and not their
workers
it's a big issue it's a very interesting
question about living wage because it
depends on where you live to live here
in new york city that would be very
tough to live on 28 000 a year
especially if you're married and you
have a family
you could go to another part of the
country and maybe you'd do okay i don't
i don't know where that is actually but
living wage really depends on where you
live i mean people will debate it but to
me a good job is a job that gives you a
chance to own a home to save someone for
retirement so you can retire with
dignity and to do something for your own
children saving for their education and
the jobs that are being created in the
biggest numbers in this country for
people who don't have a degree don't do
that they don't even come close and
there once was a time when you can pull
the wool over the employee's eyes
but you know ignorance is bliss until
you focus on who's getting rich and when
you see the gap between those who are
working and the execs and shareholders
that's when people start grabbing these
signs and saying we are going to stand
not just for us but for our kids and
their kids as well so the dynamic may be
changing we may look back and say this
was a year when there was a new movement
that changed the state of working in
america great peace good job man